several regular unemployment insurance
claimants have been
wondering what will happen now that a
certain extension expired this past
weekend well joe moeller has been
looking into that
he joins us now live with what he's
learned joe yeah well
due to the stimulus bill taking so long
the new benefits have obviously not
kicked in yet and i won't for a few
weeks at least a few weeks uh we have
been getting contacted by a number of
people who still have some questions and
concerns
about the extensions that they are
filing saturday
my seb plus they said exhausted
sharon wally is one of many people
without benefits now as we wait for the
stimulus bill to kick in
i've been online with people i said what
happens with the the new
trump peuc i was told to keep filing
because i haven't found work
so i don't know what to do her seb
extended benefits ran out over the
weekend
many claimants had regular ui benefits
exhausted under the peuc extension the
big problem with it was that
we obviously waited a little too late to
sign that initial bill
sierra neal runs the unemployment nevada
information and help facebook group
she says while dieter waits for
department of labor direction on the new
stimulus bill
some benefits will remain exhausted they
forced
everybody to file the state extended
benefits
when everything expired on the 26th so
peuc benefits ended and claimants say
they were forced to begin the seb
benefits
neil says once dieter implements the
changes claimants will eventually be
able to use the old peuc benefits
if you got on an scb last week after the
december 26
deadline you will revert back
and get that 11 weeks on peuc monday
dieter explained they must wait for
direction for the department of labor
and that could take weeks
and we did reach out to dieter today for
some more clarification
on this and the peuc benefits when they
do return we're waiting for
uh an answer on that and several other
questions so stay with us here on eight
news now for the latest
on that reporting live joe moeller i'll
send it back to you
and joe as we do wait for the stimulus
bill to be implemented in our state do
we know how long people will be
out of benefits
well yeah thousands of people are gonna
be waiting for it for some time we know
that the department of labor is gonna
take
at least two weeks to get the
information to dieter and then there
will be some time after that so people
could be waiting up to four weeks
uh for their benefits so it is suggested
some people who run the popular facebook
pages have suggested that
maybe uh people when they get their
stimulus checks that are starting to be
dispersed tonight
they should hold on to those and spend
them very wisely we'll send it back to
you